foreign
[Music]
ER I'm the president and chief
scientific officer for careless life
sciences and I'm here today to talk to
you about advances in liquid biopsy and
so as we start to think about the
opportunity the liquid biopsy performs
and affords us I think it's important to
start to think about this in the broader
context of the systems that we're trying
to interrogate and understand and really
Advance our ability to intervene within
Advanced malignancies and ideally other
diseases as well and so as we start to
evaluate the opportunity it's really
important to start to think about how we
can move from a symptomatic definition
of disease to a molecular definition of
disease today and previously we've
always used symptoms to Define how we
started to characterize disease that's
something that has been developed
because of inherent limitations in
technology that exists whereas today
with Next Generation sequencing we're
able to start to move beyond that and so
we're finally able to start to look at
the molecular nature of cells what
perturbations are driving disease and
Define that in a way that allows a finer
resolution for each underlying
malignancy type so as we start to think
about this and we can approach it from a
mathematical perspective and this is
really a a highly complex system that is
adapting to evolutionary pressure
applied through various therapeutic
interventions and so what we really want
to start to do is understand where
exactly are the Tipping points how we
can how can we push one patient's
response in one particular direction
compared to another uh and and that's
what Precision medicine affords us
that's what we can start to do with this
information that we're able to generate
in Mass across a multitude of different
patients and so as we start to think
about the complexity of the data we also
also want to be keenly aware of first
principles
so of course when we're talking about
molecular biology we've got to go
through that central dogma so we've got
about 20 000 genes that we can measure
and those turns into hundreds of
thousands of transcripts of which maybe
000 or so are most most useful those are
turned into millions of different
proteins and protein complexes we try to
contain them and estimate the number uh
but really we don't have the technology
that's capable of addressing the sheer
complexity that exists within our system
and so we're using surrogate data points
and so you know inevitably we start to
rely on DNA I it's the easiest thing to
measure but it has its own limitations
and so we go to the RNA and we're
capable of measuring that fairly well
but it also has its limitations and so
as we start to understand uh the nature
of the molecular information that we're
generating it's also important to be
aware of the limitations of those data
sources that at the end of the day it's
not the DNA that's driving everything
it's really the formation of these
protein complexes but we have to use the
surrogate information that's available
to us and a really good example of how
DNA and mutations don't tell the whole
story is actually the domesticated swine
and so in captivity uh they're stuck in
a permanently juvenile state that is due
to diet is due to a low stress
environment but when they escape it can
take as little as three months for them
to go through a pretty significant
phenotypic transformation they grow
these large tusks they get Harry
there's no change at the DNA level this
is only a change within the phenotypic
presentation of the animal due to
changes in testosterone due to changes
in the hormonal system and so as we
start to think about you know what
information can we glean from DNA what
information can we gleaned from RNA and
how do we get to where we can actually
measure everything in the protein it's
important to be aware of the limitations
of that information
now that being said we're on the cusp of
a revolution in science and molecular
science because of the invention of Next
Generation sequencing and if you think
about the context of that uh it's
actually very akin to the invention of a
microscope and so back in the day before
we had microscopes we had no idea about
germs and bacteria but once we could
start to see them then all of a sudden
we could start to understand them and
arguably the invention of penicillin and
of antibiotics has led to more uh
Improvement in human health than
anything else uh ever and so now with
Next Generation sequencing we're in a
similar situation we have the
opportunity to make measurements and see
things that we can never know before and
so it's up to us to utilize that
information to maximize our ability to
improve The Human Condition
and so as we start to think about that
technological uh Revolution that's
really underway it comes down to some
very uh simple numbers large numbers but
simple numbers so if we normalize uh
everything to the data required uh to
look at a hundred thousand patients at
500x depths of coverage across their
exome and their transcriptome then we
can start to look at the relative cost
and improvements in technology and so if
we tried to measure those hundred
thousand patients at 500x depth of
coverage back in 2001 that would have
cost over 20 trillion dollars now if we
tried to do it in 2011 it would have
cost over three billion dollars today
when we do it it's costing more like 150
million dollars which is still a lot of
money but relative to the amount of data
that we're getting out is reasonable to
start to pursue and so it's incumbent
upon us to start to gather as much of
this information as possible because
it's only by looking at everything that
we're going to be able to start to truly
understand how best to intervene on a
patient's behalf to you know improve
their uh particular outcome
so you know right now we have a habit of
defining genes as being clinically
actionable or not which is really more a
function of the available therapies and
not the necessarily the genes themselves
and so as we start to think about how
many genes are there that are cancer
genes how many genes that matter uh the
answer uh maybe not surprisingly is is
basically all of them every Gene is a
cancer Gene and so there's been some
nice work evaluating this lately and so
if we look at it of the 17
000 genes that have been published on in
PubMed 87 of them have at least one
mention of cancer and so at the end of
the day you know we know that every
single Gene can be involved in cancer it
doesn't mean it's the driver but it
means that it can be a passenger and
then by understanding the perturbations
within the molecular system we're going
to increase our understanding of how
best to identify and intervene on
patients behalf and so you know we've
focused all our efforts on a relatively
small number of genes because they've
given us the biggest impact but also
because of the technological limitations
it wasn't really feasible to run whole
exome and whole transcriptome on every
single cancer patient but it is now the
technology is available to us and we can
do this in routine clinical testing to
be able to gather this information and
really start to expand our understanding
of patients uh disease and how best to
to make it better for them to find new
opportunities to treat them to find new
drug targets and develop new improved
therapies and so at the end of the day
that diagnosis is of critical importance
it's the first step in this process and
one that we can improve upon because at
the end of the day you know the very
first step in treating a disease is
diagnosing it so as we start to look at
the nature of the molecular aberrations
behind cancer types we can see these
patterns in the underlying mutational
Spectrum we can see patterns within the
expression profile within the copy
number profile that enable us to
identify these particular diseases and
is eventually going to lead to new
definitions of various cancer subtypes
that are driven by the particular
alteration that is the foundational
element in the cancer and so we can look
at the work that's already been done
looking at tissue specific molecular
alterations and how that can help Define
and differentiate disease types that's
especially important when we don't know
the primary about five to seven percent
of cancer patients metastatic cancer
patients do not know what type of cancer
they have and so the way that we treat a
lung cancer is very very different than
the way we treated colorectal cancer
patients or pancreatic cancer patients
and so knowing the nature of that
disease is of critical importance and
something that the molecular information
that we're now able to generate can
provide a significant role in improving
and defining and so as we start to think
about this and as we start to put into
context the ability to measure all of
these different genes both at the DNA
and the RNA level it really creates a
new opportunity uh and so you know I've
had access to this data set from Charis
of over 145 000 whole transcriptomes and
and with this we can start to see
patterns in the biology of cancer that
allow us to start to refine and Define
disease in a new way
and so when we're dealing with these
incredibly large data sets it's all
about uh d-dimensionalization reduction
in the dimensionality of the data we
can't truly handle millions and millions
of data points per patients uh because
the false Discovery risk is incredibly
high and so we can use our knowledge of
biology of Pathways of genes that are
associated with one another to reduce
that underlying question and come up
with features that allow us to start to
Define disease in new ways and so we did
a 28 000 d-dimensionalization of the
data and then did a non-supervised
clustering and that allows us to see
these very distinct and related groups
of patients patients whose disease is
very similar at the molecular level but
what does that mean how can we start to
make sense of this and so we can start
turning on labels for the type of cancer
that is there and so if we look at colon
cancer that generally clusters in one
particular area but there are outliers
there are different types of cancer that
we all lump together today but maybe we
shouldn't if we start to look at lung
cancer at ovarian cancer at glioblastoma
very very distinct biological uh cluster
something that is very different from
everything else that we know about
cancer now all of these start to emerge
as very distinct opportunities to
enhance our understanding of disease and
at the end of the day every disease is
going to be that and this is just a
two-dimensional representation of a 28
000 dimensional space but it provides
context in terms of how we can start to
use this molecular information to better
Define and understand disease so you may
be asking yourself what does that have
to do with liquid biopsy why am I
talking about expression of tissue it's
because this is the foundational of
Truth so the opportunity afforded with
liquid biopsy is to have an insight into
what's happening in the tissue through
this non-invasive procedure
and so we want to understand how much of
this information from the tissue are we
able to find uh in the blood and that
comes down to the underlying biological
substrates that are available to us uh
and so we can start to look at
circulating tumor DNA we can look at
circulating tumor RNA we can look at
exosomally derived or extracellular
vesicle derived RNA we can look at
circulating tumor cells we can look at
tumor-educated platelets for the most
part today liquid biopsies are focused
on circulating tumor DNA that's a missed
opportunity the RNA component is very
very uh full of information and so by
adding in RNA we can do a lot more
uh circulating tumor cells have been
studied for a long time they're more
rare it's a more mature but difficult
source of information uh and the tumor
educated platelets are still a little
bit early I think uh so my main focus is
going to be on these three areas in
terms of biological sources of
information and so as we're measuring
these uh the context of what we're doing
is of critical importance because if we
just look what's in the plasma we're
missing something what we're missing is
what's in The Buffy coat that genomic
component uh for what's there and that
has a very important role to play that
I'll come to uh in a little bit but our
ability to measure things should be the
rate limiting factor and it's not uh and
so running smaller Gene panels is is
squandering an opportunity to maximize
our understanding on a per patient basis
and so what we really want to do is try
to find solutions to inherent biological
limitation
uh there's a relatively small percentage
of patients that have a lot of
circulating cell free DNA
as the stage of cancer advances the
number gets larger but we need to be
aware of these limitations and try to
maximize our ability uh to do the right
thing by patients we want to miss as
little as we can we don't want to call
things positive that shouldn't and we
might as well take the opportunity to
get that hereditary piece of information
and so there are a number of technical
challenges both biological and from the
technological perspective
that are limiting our ability to
maximize our information and I'm going
to go through a fair number of those and
so addressing things like complex
signatures loh and tnp require a deeper
understanding of what's going on and so
we need to start to look at you know how
many unique biological molecules can we
actually measure out of the blood
because that's a driver for the depth
and the depth is the fundamental
attribute that defines the underlying
limited detection for these rare
biological events and so
if we consider this and it's
colloquially called the shedding problem
uh we know that it varies by tumor type
we know that it varies by stage of
disease and so uh the more aggressive
the tumor type is the more well
vascularized the tumor type is in
general the more cell free DNA there is
circulating tumor DNA and the later the
stage the more there is and so this
provides a framework by which we can
start to evaluate the opportunity
because if we're only able to find you
know cell free DNA or circulating tumor
DNA in 40 of stage one cancer patients
well that means that's at best for early
detection we're going to maximize our
sensitivity at 40 percent if we're only
looking at circulating tumor DNA so it's
of critical importance that we be aware
of these underlying limitations and put
them into context
another really important component uh is
to look for false positives so the
underlying number of mutations and the
mutations observed in plasma are not all
tumor derived there's a very significant
contribution from clonal hematopoiesis
of indeterminate potential chip
mutations for short and those are
important to start subtracting out we
don't want to start to act on these uh
they're very common as it turns out it's
a function of age of the patient and so
the older we get the more of these
accumulate and a lot of the genes that
are mutated are also mutated in cancer
and so we want to be cognizant of the
fact that when we see these somatic
events and they are somatic events
they're just not tumor derived they're
coming from an alternative source and
the last thing we want to do is treat a
patient based upon a chip mutation where
we're not attacking the tumor when we
think we are and this is a very real
thing and so about 10 percent of men
with advanced prostate cancer have a
chip mutation and often in ATM and that
could lead them to being treated with a
parp inhibitor when they should not be
and so it's really important to start to
understand these and we can do much
better if we sequence both the plasma
fraction and the white blood fraction
because we can start to understand what
is Chip and what is not chip not always
it's going to be difficult especially in
those really low varying frequency
events when the two populations converge
but the more insight we can have the
better and this is part of the learning
that is ahead of us we need to be able
to start to understand you know what is
actionable what is not actionable what
is a an accumulation of white blood
cells as opposed to what is coming from
the tumor and so that's the opportunity
that is afforded by the advancements in
the technology where we can actually
start to measure more than just what's
in the plasma another component of
course are the germline alterations if
we're going in and we're measuring
what's in that puffy coat anyway then
we're going to be picking up those 50
alterations that are almost certainly
inherited uh and so we shouldn't just
turn a blind eye to that we need to
evaluate this we need to be mindful of
the impact that that can have on the
patient's family and their progeny and
so
including an assessment of germline is
part of that workup because uh as we
have begun to understand the number of
patients that have a germline pathogenic
mutations uh is quite significant it's
somewhere in that eight to fifteen
percent
um and the more data we collect the more
we can start to see it the more advanced
disease uh the more often we're finding
them and so you know these last three
studies are probably the best studies
but they're targeting different patient
populations so tcga has a lot more
earlier stage disease than the studies
coming out of Indiana and Michigan uh
and so when we're talking about later
stage disease and you know it's probably
up here in that 12 to 15 percent uh
earlier stage disease it's going to be a
little bit less uh and so again putting
it into context is important and then
the final component uh arguably the most
important components are the false
negatives so what do you do when you
know the tumor is harboring a mutation
but you cannot find it in the blood is
that because of a technological
limitation is it because of a biological
limitation or is it due to the
underlying evolution of the tumor in
response to therapy we have to consider
all the different reasons why that can
be happening because in general when you
use tissue as the gold standard blood
you're only getting somewhere between 55
and 65 percent concordance and so
there's a significant number of
mutations that do not show up in the
blood and are known to be in the tumor
it's a difficult number to get to though
because most of the patients involved in
these studies were receiving treatment
or had received treatment so these are
not necessarily time contiguous sample
collections which would be important to
do the best possible job of assessing
this
and so at the end of the day though this
limitation of sensitivity is a function
of the number of biological molecules
that can be measured and so what we want
to do is maximize the number of
biological molecules that we're capable
of measuring and what that comes down to
uh is looking for as many sources of
information as we can that's the
advantage of going to cell free DNA and
cell free RNA so we can think about
things not in terms of the underlying
nature of the molecule but you know
circulating nucleic acids in general and
so the CNA opportunity is significant
because if we think about it you know in
one nanogram of DNA you've got about 300
copies of each gene and one nanogram of
mRNA you've got about 10 000 copies of
each gene so by adding in that secondary
source of biological information in
terms of RNA we're expanding the number
of unique molecules that are going into
the acids and that is the fundamental
driver of assay
so as much as we want to sequence you
know that is not the rate limitation
what's rate limiting are the number of
molecules we can put into the assay now
we're doing PCR as part of next
Generation sequencing and so now you can
sequence uh 30 000 X depth of coverage
or 50 000 steps of coverage if you want
uh but that's not adding additional
information because at the end of the
day we're not adding in hundreds of
nanograms of underlying material we're
lucky to get 20 25 nanograms of material
so it's that biological input that is
rate limiting and it's really important
to put that into context because if
somebody is reporting very very high
depths of coverage they're certainly
counting TCR duplicates uh and that's
not new information that is just a
rehashing of information that we already
have so it's the unique biological
measurements that matter the most and we
can look at that relationship between
nanograms and depth and loss and limited
detection and so we can think about this
in terms of those areas of the genome
that are relatively easy to measure and
hybridize to and pull down as opposed to
those that are more difficult and so the
lower the depth uh the more difficult it
is in cases where you have uniformity
but it creates this gradation
and so if we want to hit
um and we can reverse the process if we
let's say we want 0.1 percent varying
frequency in terms of limited detection
uh and we want five observations of that
mutation well then we need a depth of
5000x to get to a depth of 5000x if
we've got good quality region then we
need over 60 nanograms of input uh if
it's a really tough reach into sequence
we may never get there and so looking at
the nature of what we're observing
looking at uh the potential for for
increase or decrease depth based upon
the inherent sequence is essential to
put this type of data into context and
so
now this is a fundamental limitation not
of liquid biopsy per se but of the
biology of what's measurable in the
blood
um and so if we pull two tubes uh two 10
mil tubes uh from a patient we can get
eight mils of plasma in eight mils of
plasma you're still going to be limited
you're still going to be lucky to get 30
40 nanograms of of cell free material
out to and that's a rare patient in many
cases it's going to be much much smaller
in terms of the amount of material that
we have and so it becomes absolutely
essential for us to understand you know
how much material went into this assay
because that's going to be the driver of
how sensitive we can be in finding these
mutations and how much we can trust them
if we see them lower than that there's a
lot of noise in these systems there's a
lot of sequencing air that can be
introduced and we don't want to mistake
sequencing air for something that is
biologically uh real that's a different
type of false positive that is equally
or more dangerous for patients and so as
we start to think about this opportunity
we can start to Define our ability to
see these things and relate it back to
the tumor uh in terms of that
non-shedder rate to say okay if we have
less than five nanograms uh then we're
not going to run it if we have less than
10 nanograms we're not going to run it
and what does that do in terms of the
percentage of non-shitter the larger you
make that threshold the higher your
non-shatter rate if we accept all comers
then we can sit in that 40 percent
concordance some coming from the DNA
some coming from the RNA what we know is
that the combination of the two is
better as we get more material as we
force there to be more material than if
things improve but at the expense of not
being able to provide information for
patients and so well there's this
natural trade-off in terms of you know
how many people can we help and how well
can we
um and we don't necessarily need to set
strict thresholds but we do need to be
cognizant of the limitations uh and it
should be well reported for this
particular input what is the limit of
detection uh for this patient because
that's easily determined uh and
something that patients deserve to know
and doctors deserve to know and so as we
you know go from kind of down in the
weeds of the technical attributes of
liquid biopsy and think about you know
what is the opportunity that is you know
in front of us with this technology it's
really well beyond oncology
um and so at the end of the day every
single disease out there is cells going
wrong and if the cells are going wrong
that means that there's something within
the molecular system that's going wrong
and the more data we collect the better
we're going to understand these and we
have a very unique opportunity in
oncology because we actually have access
to the raw cells to the diseased cells
and so we know what ground truth is and
we can start to compare what we observe
in the blood back to that ground truth
and that enables us to start to advance
these assays and these techniques
so utilization of this technology and
the learnings in oncology should be
applied elsewhere because with
Alzheimer's disease you can't go in
there and biopsy the brain of a patient
you don't know what it is that we're
looking for and so as we can start to
understand the relationship between uh
aberrant molecular signaling in the
tissue and those features that we're
able to see in the blood in oncology we
can use those learnings and start to
apply them elsewhere and so at the end
of the day this technology very much is
the new microscope it is a new molecular
measurement system that properly
utilized is going to redefine medicine
as we know it and so it's incumbent upon
us to make sure that we're well defined
that we are properly defining the
limitations of these Technologies as
well as the opportunities
because this is going to be the future
teacher of all medicine can see that day
when every single patient is getting a
blood draw and we're sequencing
everything that's in there and able to
Define you're at risk of developing uh
lupus or you're at the risk of
developing rheumatoid arthritis or
you're in the early stages of Dementia
or you have pancreatic cancer and so
it's really incumbent upon us as the
scientific Community to be very thorough
in the development of these Technologies
and make sure that we're preparing the
world for the opportunity uh in front of
us because what we're experiencing
really is a molecular revolution in
medicine and the opportunity to improve
The Human Condition is is greater than
anything else in the history uh of
science uh and so with that I would like
to to thank you for your attention
um and hope that you're enjoying the
conference thank you very much